I liked the art bill buildup because so
everybody likes the art bell buildup,
the art bell sound,
you know what did,
what did he say from the Kingdom of Nih
and Nih?
PAHRUMP,
Nevada.
I used to always love our bell because
someone would call in and say,
I'm aware wolf,
and here we go.
Ooh,
my interesting.
Tell me more.
He didn't care.
He never.
He never called you out on it.
Just let you let you ramble.
Hit time.
Traveler lines.
Loved the people.
Loved it.
I never learned anything from it though.
So you're obsessed with Ufo,
right?
Is that safe to say?
It's safe to say,
but it's not so much just the Ufo at its
self.
I mean there.
I don't call them that anymore,
that we call these advanced aerial
threats.
There are different threats.
You were honed in our word.
We weren't supposed to really get into
here in the first part of the show.
Did you have a plan?
I have a very.
I have a very long plan.
Detailed plan.
We're going to start with my body.
We're just going to talk about my body
for a lot and.
Okay.
What do you want to talk about in terms
of your body?
Well,
my body is interesting.
It's unique.
It changes shape and what I've noticed
is it's just changing.
It's getting larger and larger,
getting wider pending upon what you put
in it.
But you're off.
Can I cuss?
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
We're on the Internet.
You're still fucking fit.
You shook my hand.
I think it would break my hand.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
just don't be strong.
I didn't mean to.
Don't be.
You're shaking your hand.
Just thought it was a handshake.
I know.
Well,
it's one of those power moves you ever
see when trump shakes people's hands and
he pulls them in and he's like,
yeah,
he does do weird shit.
Does weird shit like that.
Yeah.
I didn't mean to do that.
It just meant to shake your hand like a
man.
Well,
I,
I took it as like know your place
motherfucker.
Oh this is my show.
I didn't think that.
No,
I'm just joking.
Interesting.
Um,
so how,
when did you get obsessed with this
aerial threat thing and why?
Why do you,
why do you call them threats?
Uh,
we'll get into that I guess.
Um,
but,
uh,
I got into when I was in junior high,
um,
for some weird reason I had like some
time off in,
um,
and I went to the school library and
like seventh grade and I was like,
damn,
I gotta read some Boring Shit,
what am I going to read?
And I saw this one book and it had a
picture of the lochness monster and like
a,
you have almost,
that looks cool.
And I read that and I was like,
holy cow,
these are like real.
It wasn't all science fiction.
I mean the way the book was laid out,
it's like these are like real event and
so I'm all,
there's no,
no way really.
And then,
uh,
when the band started doing it,
staying in the back of the van,
there were no smartphones.
So as we were buying books and um,
and I would just lay there,
we'd have like 20 hour drives and,
and so I started buying books on the Ufo
phenomenon and I was,
want you to do that.
It's a black hole.
You're done.
Yeah,
it's definitely a rabbit hole.
You get sucked into it.
I,
uh,
my house,
I have a frame poster that's the cover
of the Roswell Daily News shows the day
after the Roswell crash where it says
that the air force came and recovered
the wreckage and,
you know,
the whole deal.
I've been obsessed with this shit.
I was a little kid.
Yeah.
Uh,
I think,
I think that's a,
I think that's by design.
I think that this generation is a,
was meant to have this stuff come out.
Um,
but,
you know,
I can't prove that.
That's just my feeling.
What would it makes you feel that like,
um,
because of exactly what you said,
there was a lot of people.
I don't believe that some of the,
um,
I don't believe that some of the events
happened on accident.
You know,
I think that,
uh,
there's been a lot of events that are on
purpose,
some have been for show,
some have been for um,
human,
there's a variety of,
a variety of reasons,
but I think a lot of it is a control
system that's really pushing humanity in
a very specific direction.
And uh,
so like they've got a timeframe where
they had these events take place.
Is that what you think?
Yeah.
And they also time travel,
which is different than what people
think in like a movie where they sit in
a machine and you often,
you're in the 19 thirties and you got to
go save humanity.
Um,
when you use the technology,
you have a,
there's a time a difference between
where,
what they're doing inside of an article
artificially created bubble of gravity
of sorts.
And then what's on the outside.
So if you're on the inside of one of
those machines,
everything would be skewed more black
and white.
There'd be like a red shift and
everybody would look frozen.
So you literally could fly around and
grab a coke out of someone's hand and
put it in someone else's hand.
It's really,
where are you getting this from?
Will take a wild guess.
Look at the people I'm surrounded by,
you know,
so,
so the people you're surrounded by are
telling you this is what it is a well,
I don't want to get into that,
but the people I'm surrounded with,
um,
and myself,
uh,
you know,
are very close to this stuff.
But the physics,
you know,
the physicist that's a Co founder of my
company to the star,
he's a Nobel nominee.
He wrote the book on Plasma Physics.
He,
what's his name?
Uh,
Hal put off Dr Hal put off and he,
he created remote viewing.
Do you know what remote viewing is?
He's the creator of the CIA psychics spy
program.
But he also has done like really exotic,
advanced forefront propulsion work for
the past decades and decades actually.
I mean,
he,
he's deep into like quantum,
this and that.
So he's the one that actually told me
about the red shift.
Yeah.
And so they have experienced this
physically or is this just theoretical
or they know that it exists?
Like the technology?
Yes.
Uh,
I,
I believe that the technology,
uh,
not only exists,
we've figured out how to play with it,
but I'm not going to really get into
that here.
I what,
what that is what we're doing at my
company though.
That is the announcement.
So Steve Justice was head of advanced
programs that the skunk works and the
skunkworks or who built,
you know,
the famous secret basis,
you hear about skunk works,
did you know the u two spy plane,
the SR seven one blackbird,
1:17 style fighter and it's all groom
lake out there,
all that kind of stuff.
And um,
and he literally was in charge of all
the advanced program.
So,
you know,
you've got the boss and you got him and
um,
he came,
uh,
he just finished his career over there
within the past two months.
I think it is an.
And he was on stage with me when we came
out and said,
we're going to be building one of these
things.
So when,
when you save it,
this,
all this technology exists,
have they explained this to you or have
you seen it physically?
Oh,
I haven't seen anything physically like
that.
I'm not,
I wouldn't be allowed to go anywhere if
that does or doesn't exist.
So they've just explained to you that
this exists and that this is in the
hands of the US government.
This I think.
No,
no,
I see.
I don't want to get into that kind of
stuff.
But um,
if you don't mind,
well why is it that you want to not get
into certain things?
Well,
I don't want to speak act,
you know,
I represent more than myself these days.
So,
uh,
I definitely have to watch what I say.
Who Do you represent when you say
represent more than yourself?
The team that I'm with.
So when you look at the people that are
a part of my company,
it's under secretary of defense's and
defense and senior intelligence service.
Is there a list of these people like
that we could see?
Oh yeah.
I thought you guys would have had that
list where folks could see it online.
Oh yeah,
they can go to,
um,
to the Stars Academy Dot Com.
Scroll down and you'll be able to see
who they all are.
So,
so how did you get linked up with all
these people?
That story might be a better way to
start because a lot of people don't know
this part of the story and I think
you're going to find it pretty funny.
Odd as well.
But uh,
okay.
So we'll back up a couple of years.
So,
um,
I have,
I was obviously,
and you know,
I started the band blink and blink went
places and um,
and then uh,
but we always had a weird band
relationship,
like most bands and we also thought that
we would never be big.
So we started companies on the side and
I had a company that incubated a lot of
small startups like software and apparel
and hardcore skate surf companies and
stuff like that.
Well,
I learned a lot from that and I pulled
out and entertainment startup called to
the stars and I knew I was going to be
doing kind of like science fiction,
franchised stories just like Disney,
but science fiction for adults.
And what that means is,
you know,
I make a story,
I title it,
I brand it and I put out the book and I
put up the merchandise and I go make a
movie,
you know,
and it's,
it's a,
it's a vertically integrated kind of
model.
Well,
one of the stories I knew I wanted to
put out with secret machines,
which was kind of a historical fiction,
um,
but based on real events about the UFO
phenomenon,
but I also knew that I knew shit that
most people don't know because I've
studied it for so long and I happened to
put some pieces together that most
people don't put together.
So before I came out with that book and
before I came out with the plan to take
that,
make major motion pictures and all that
kind of stuff,
um,
I,
I knew I needed to ask permission.
So I flew,
I flew around to places it can't say who
they were,
but,
and they,
they listened to my pitch and um,
and then I got a,
I got a email out of nowhere that says
meet us next to the Pentagon at this day
and time.
And I did that.
And from mapping email from just,
I just tend to person.
No,
no,
I just can't tell you who it's from.
And so then I go out the next to the
Pentagon.
So you just go to the Pentagon.
I flew out depending on city.
Yeah.
It's like,
dude,
this is freaking out.
I'll tell you,
when I started freaking out,
there's more shit.
It gets way worse.
This is nothing.
Um,
so that started me out in,
out near DC,
taking some other high level meetings
and there was somebody at a very high
level that,
that,
uh,
close the door with many.
I says,
okay,
I'm going to introduce you to somebody
and that person comes to San Diego,
puts me on the phone with a general.
And the general is listening to my
little stump speech about what I want to
do with this franchise because it was,
I definitely didn't want to,
you know,
I wasn't looking to like force
disclosure and I wasn't looking to be
rogue and break secrets.
I was like,
look,
I know what's going on here and you guys
are doing a kick ass job.
And I would have done the exact same
thing.
Should I have been the guy at the top
that had to make some really hardcore
decisions 70 years ago.
So I'm,
I want to support you.
I think people are cynical because
there's a vacuum.
You guys can't say what you're doing.
So all these people are just coming up
with a bunch of bullshit to say,
Oh,
you know,
they don't want us to know or we can't
handle it.
Or it's all about oil and money and all
this weird shit.
And you would put these pieces together
and independently I did.
And so based on books that you read,
yet people think,
you know,
people think that places like the CIA
and the dia,
all these intelligence organizations
have,
um,
you know,
a monopoly on information.
They don't,
they get their information from the real
world too,
you know,
uh,
they do have access to,
to,
you know,
archives of information.
They do have access to some amazing
satellite data and stuff like that.
But if you're smart and you take your
time,
you know where to look and you find
patterns,
um,
you can pretty much put together all the
same shit.
They can kind of,
you know.
And that's what I did.
And so when I pitched what I wanted to
do,
he said,
come up and meet me tomorrow.
And so I flew up to NASA,
actually a Nasa Ames and had a two hour
meeting there.
And after two hours,
that person says,
he looks me in the eyes,
I'm going to introduce you to someone
else.
And he did.
And so I got on the phone with this
person and this person,
you know,
I'm a skeptic,
I'm a skeptic.
And then at the end of the conversation
he goes,
um,
fly out and see me.
And so I did and that's when things
really started happening.
So I mean now I fly out to this airport
and I,
I sit at a table in a restaurant at the
airport,
no one's in there and this gentleman
sits down and the waiter comes up,
he waves off the waiter and he
looks me in the eye and says it was the
Cold War and we found a life form and
that's when I started shitting my pants
because I know a lot about this stuff.
But you always wait to talk to somebody
that is one of the inside people you
always want to have sits down at a
restaurant with you at the airport and
tells you that they found a life form.
Yes.
And during the Cold War,
during the Cold War and everything that
they did in every decision they made at
the time was because of the
consciousness of the Cold War.
Why's this guy decided to meet with you
in an airport?
Because the only way you meet with these
people,
the only way you ever would have anyone
talk to you is if you can provide a
service that they need.
And my service was pretty interesting to
them because I said,
look,
you guys,
you know,
you struggle with saying,
disclosure,
you want to tell everybody everything,
which I don't think everyone should know
everything.
Um,
and then you say they can't handle it,
so don't tell them anything,
you know.
And I'm like,
there's,
there's a middle road there and here's
the way I would do the middle road.
And it resonated with them,
you know.
And so we had a pretty epic conversation
for two hours.
Why you like,
why,
what is it about what your message was?
You're idea was,
um,
the,
made them something to tell you some top
secret shit that they've tried to keep
away from the American people.
When you tell your guy who was like a
big celebrity who's in a huge rock band
like you and just say,
Hey,
meet me in an airport.
I'm going to tell you about a life form
that we found during the Cold War.
Because you're famous or because you
know things?
No,
because I have a service,
so it's,
it's not a,
it sounds easy when you play it like
that.
But if service,
a service,
like what can you do for them that they
need help with communication.
They don't have a way to make a movie a
book.
They don't know.
They don't have a way to make
documentaries.
They don't have a way to go on,
on a big show like this and communicate
with young people.
They don't do that.
And nor should they,
they're,
they look at you gotta.
Look at what they're doing.
Um,
so they look to you for a spokesperson
role.
I wouldn't say spokesperson
communication,
role,
role.
It makes sense.
They would give some information to you
and you would get it out to people.
And now why wouldn't they do it
themselves?
Because they wouldn't have the same
platform.
They don't have the same platform.
And the other reason is as people have
tried to do movies and stuff like this,
but none of none of them know.
I was fortunate enough to,
to know the core story.
And most people don't explain that then
if you don't mind going back,
like you said,
that you were able to put things
together that other people weren't one
of those things.
Essentially it's the book secret
machines where you have a lot of private
finance,
you have some world bankers and you
have,
um,
a lot of people internationally working
together to figure out a plan of how to,
how to push back against something
that's been coming here for a very long
time.
But using off the books,
finances and using mechanisms that,
that we're not totally aware exist.
And what people have to realize is,
you know,
they,
the UFO phenomenon isn't a phenomenon.
There's the universe is fucking gigantic
and there's life everywhere,
every fucking where and,
and,
and there's a lot of life that's way
more advanced than we are.
And just like voyager left our solar
system,
a little dinky satellite from the
seventies there.
And just like,
my company's going to be building,
you know,
this,
this electromagnetic craft that really
can do the same thing.
The time that I've been telling you
about.
Other civilizations have that too,
which means you can traverse those
distances of space and what you have to
think about is what happened when we
first discovered that and what did we do
about it?
And there's no,
you know,
you've got to look at 47 in a very
peculiar way.
Ninety days after the Roseville event
with CIA was created,
the air force was separated from the
army.
The National Security Act was created
and all those things are mechanisms to
start learning more and to start getting
private industry off the ground.
So they're going to do with World War
II.
You think it had to do with aliens?
Oh,
I absolutely think it.
Well,
both because what,
uh,
what I believe crashed at Roswell was,
um,
I believe it was German from Argentina,
but it had hallmarks and technology
based on alien technology.
So we put out a story saying it's alien
and then we put out a story saying it's
a weather balloon,
but the real thing it was we didn't want
anyone to guess and that's why we put
those two things out there.
And that's Kinda how they do it.
I think they did that with the moon.
It's like,
you know,
we went to the moon and then they put
out this meme kind of thing,
like we can't,
we,
we didn't go to the moon,
but I didn't want people really going,
well,
what's on the moon that,
you know,
so these things are managed until they
can figure it out because you've got a
bunch of normal dudes in suits sitting
at a big table like this and it's their
fucking responsibility to figure this
thing out and this shit is monumentally
big.
Um,
but back to how they manage this.
Then how these regular dudes without
access to communication like you have,
how have they managed to disseminate
this information and,
and,
and sort of confuse everybody.
I think.
Well,
I can tell.
I don't know how they did it.
I do know that they infiltrated Ufo
groups.
That was the very first thing they did
in the fifties,
sort of like how FBI agents and
undercover cops infiltrated occupy Wall
Street yet pretended to be radical
hippies and started fights.
Yep.
They did that.
They get access to what the civilians
are learning.
How information transfers from one group
to another and then they start
deflecting all their knowledge and
putting in leaks and this and that and
getting them off the main track,
not because of disdain for citizens and
not because
of any other reason than picture isis.
We don't know what Isis is.
They got a nuclear bomb and we caught a
guy trying to sneak in this mom.
Right.
Are they going to stop and come sit on
your couch and tell you all about it?
No.
And if you're like on the radio and
there's all these people going,
oh my God,
we're gonna die.
Obama,
Obama there.
Hold up a second.
You know,
you're not going to fucking die,
but we need to learn more about this and
we've got to figure it out before we sit
down and talk to you about it.
So what was the connection though
specifically that you had figured out
that they knew,
that you had figured out that people
hadn't put together?
Well,
let me just.
Okay,
so let me go back to my story.
So I put out this book and this book
deals with a book called the secret
machines and it deals with secret,
you know,
international finance,
private industry.
I'm a secret space program,
uh,
and a bunch of other things that your
research is both.
What do you mean?
How'd you get the information?
I was just 25 years of reading shit and
watching videos and studying physics and
studying,
you know,
the secrecy acts and all that kind of
weird shit,
you know,
you put it together and a lot of it's
bad information.
But,
uh,
after a long time I realized I just
realized what was going on there.
I just,
I've studied enough of,
of international finance,
some mechanisms that happen after World
War Two,
what the Nazis were doing
technologically that no one really talks
about to this day.
There were a hundred years ahead of us,
uh,
about what their guys did at the end of
the war and South America that's in the
paperclip.
Paperclip was like,
there's two levels of paperclip.
Paperclip is,
is the operation that brought over all
these ex Nazis into NASA and into all of
our aerospace programs.
Why did we do that?
Well,
because they knew some shit that was
very important and we said there might
be a bigger issue out there to deal
with.
So why don't we saw with the devil or
side with someone bad because there
might be a devil out there.
It's that kind of thinking.
So they come in and thought it was about
competing with Russia to try to advance
rocketry.
The,
I believe that there was,
um,
you know,
I believe that there's a reason with the
cold war never got hot is because we're
working with Russia on this specific
issue.
You think the reason why the Cold War
never turned into an actual war.
So we were saying yeah.
So it had nothing to do with the fact
that Russia was a communist empire and
essentially,
no,
it did spent them and they really did,
went under and collapsed.
Yeah.
But there's different,
there's different levels.
It's like when someone goes,
you know,
the US government did this.
Well,
what do you mean?
What does that mean?
Does that mean the CIA did it or the Dod
did it?
Or Homeland Security did it.
You're dealing with the.
It's a trillion dollar organization.
It's like if somebody's in apple leaks
and iphone,
you know,
are you going to say,
oh my God at apple is doing.
Apple is like,
well shit,
we're a $800,000,000,000 company.
We have so many things going on
worldwide.
It's impossible to say.
The entire organization believes one
thing and the government's the same kind
of the same kind of way.
It's just like,
that's just a word.
The US government's two words,
right?
All right.
Three years,
four years.
How do we want to count this in the
United States government?
Three.
Three,
yes.
Okay.
US has got a,
you're going to find that you got to
figure this shit out.
But um,
and you have many,
many layers of what's going on and you
have some people worried on technology.
Some people worrying about what's
happening that happening to the civilian
population.
You have some people worrying about,
um,
you know,
how to keep everything afloat,
how to keep everything going.
And you have a whole bunch of weird
military excursions and they're bumping
into each other and,
and all these people aren't read in to
what's going on with the UFO thing.
So as all that shit.
So who gets read in the.
That's a good question.
If I had to guess.
I'm very,
very senior technical bras and rockstars
and Rhonda wasn't red in trust me.
They didn't tell you anything?
No.
Uh,
they possibly did,
but I wasn't read and read and I wasn't
brought into a skiff and they said this
is what's going on even though I've been
in a skiff a few times.
Okay.
You want to skip this?
A boat?
A skift is a,
is a special compart mentalized
information facility.
It's,
um,
it's,
we're top secret shit can be discussed.
I thought maybe they talk on boats
because nobody can hear you.
They do that too.
They do that.
They actually do.
Because you can sweep for bugs on boats
a lot easier than you can on a building.
Make sense?
Yeah.
So they tell you what.
Okay.
So I'm sitting at that restaurant and
says he found a live forum where they
found a life forum during the Cold War.
And I,
and I said,
well,
if find it,
oh,
I didn't ask him that question.
Get many places.
I did one time bring up.
I said,
you know,
I'm thinking about talking about what
the crash and the late forties and they
go,
why just that one?
That was the answer.
So I had to figure out a language to
talk to these guys.
Do you ever think that maybe this guy is
bullshitting you or he's crazy?
No,
fuck no,
no,
you got it.
That's what you got to hear the whole
story.
So,
um,
okay.
So I'm sitting with them,
we talk about a lot of things.
I bring up the incidents with our
nuclear weapons.
I bring up the incidences,
a,
a few other things that I want to get
into.
And um,
and he goes,
what do you need to do your project?
What do you,
what are you looking for?
And I said,
well,
I need advisors,
you know,
uh,
I need people that are from different
areas.
And the government,
because everyone has their own
perspective,
you know,
you have people at the National
Reconnaissance Office that have a
perspective based on the satellite feeds
they're getting and these things are
coming in and out of the atmosphere.
Then you also have people from the
agency that are worried about in
collecting information of what's going
on with people in different countries
and here,
uh,
but then you also have engineers that
have a perspective on how the technology
is made and what that might mean because
there's a lot of consciousness stuff
that,
that falls into this category there.
So there are satellites that track them
coming in and out of the atmosphere.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
What kinds of satellites are these?
Uh,
how the fuck,
I don't know,
usually forward looking for red,
but I don't know what spectrum of the
infrared they're looking at.
So there is some sort of a camera or
some sort of a detection device that
they have in the atmosphere just to
check for Ufo.
I don't know if it's just for you
iphones,
they can pick up very,
very specific heat signatures and they
have algorithms because what you have is
a satellite is a device that can pick up
what you,
what you program it to pick up.
Now you know,
you put a sensor on there but you got to
tell the sensor what to do.
So if the sensor says,
look something traveling at this speed
with this kind of heat,
you know,
you gotta record that you got to focus
on it and that's what we call an icbm.
But if something comes in and zigzag
stops and turns left and traveling 10
times faster than that,
we need you to record that and focusing
on that as well.
But if something just as moving low and
it's only going 300 miles an hour and it
has these big wings and Alo,
whatever,
they're all just a plain,
you know.
So the,
what it captures is based on,
you know,
how it's programmed in the first place,
but we can differentiate between media
rights and.
Absolutely,
yes.
Absolutely.
So okay.
So how often are these things coming
into?
Our Atmosphere,
oh shit,
I don't know,
but I,
I've had quite a few discussions.
I'm,
one of the people I've been,
I've been in contact with,
one of my advisors for was from the
national reconnaissance office,
high up,
high,
high up and um,
they call it episodic visits.
That's all I know.
Episodic have time periods where they,
like,
there was,
I saw a paper where they semesters,
I figured out,
um,
the department of fence figured out a
physicist there,
an algorithm of how to compute when the
things fly in,
in collect smaller ships like mothership
small ships.
What,
what at what longitude and latitude in,
in what essentially what orbit it would
land at when it would collect these
other machines.
And um,
so they tested that and in all I know is
it was successful.
They would think this is happening on a
very frequent basis.
Well,
let me tell you the rest of the story.
So I,
I,
uh,
and this is,
it's important because you'll see 'em.
So he goes,
what do you need?
I said,
I need to advisors.
And then,
uh,
so next thing you know,
I leave and two weeks later,
Bam,
my email starts.
I have all these admirals,
all these generals,
no,
no intelligence people other than,
other than bras that were connected with
the national reconnaissance office.
But,
um,
Nashville office has half air force and
half CIA.
Um,
but they're all,
they're all military.
And so I start talking to them,
I start meeting with them,
I fly out to Colorado Springs and
there's a general and a colonel and they
look at me and they said,
uh,
they said,
okay,
do you need anything else?
Are you good?
And I said,
well,
I think you guys should talk to the
defense intelligence agency.
And they go,
why?
I'm all,
I just don't want to upset them.
I want to make sure everyone's kosher
with what I'm about to do.
And uh,
the kernel looks at me and he goes,
do you ask your dad for permission after
your mom's already given it to you?
And I go,
no.
And he's all,
you've been given permission,
shut the fuck up and get to work.
And I was like,
alright.
So I did,
so I go out and I put the book out there
and I started doing national radio,
like the art bill,
so coast to coast.
Ordinarily I do all that stuff.
Next thing you know,
I get approached by somebody with a,
at a certain agency and that guy comes
to San Diego and puts me in a small
room,
uh,
and I got a,
what you would call interrogated for two
days straight saying,
um,
we need to know who the fuck you are.
You know,
shit you shouldn't know.
And uh,
what like what specifically should you
not have known?
I don't know what the book,
what's in the book,
everything I've been telling you today
when you're dealing with there,
there is a,
there is a concerted international
effort to deal with this stuff.
And that was in my book and that is,
it's not like Roswell crashed and it was
not like,
you know,
like all the typical Ufo Shit that
people dwell on isn't the story.
It's just that there's something crashed
or someone saw got abducted and saw this
or someone pulled a little piece of
metal out of their body,
but no one's put together what we're
doing about it because our,
our,
our countrymen since World War Two
aren't stupid,
is what set them off there.
Like,
what was the thing that you said that
you should not have known the A in my
book,
it is my belief,
uh,
that we have an incredible,
um,
we've made incredible strides creating a
assets to deal with this stuff.
That's,
that's my belief and I'm not speaking
for my company.
That's just nonsense.
Yeah.
I mean some sort of government agency
that has been designed or other
international international.
Okay.
So some sort of an international
collaboration to deal with the threat of
alien life and that was enough that they
pulled you aside from wouldn't let you
go for two days and just.
Yeah.
So it was the,
it was more,
it was an interrogation,
but it was a pretty heavy,
heavy debriefing of how I got to where I
was.
And it's not like they didn't let me go
home.
This took place at a hotel near my home,
but they made you sit down and talk to
them.
Oh fuck.
Yeah,
I had.
There was a six of them I think six
until they let you leave and go to sleep
and then come back,
get something.
Came back,
spent another eight hours because I
wasn't rogue.
I wasn't like trying to hide anything.
I was trying to explain to the.
How did you have all this free time
though?
What do you mean?
I mean,
have you ever like if somebody said,
hey,
we're going to have you in a room,
we're going to talk to you for two days.
I'm like,
dude,
I don't have two days or that's,
that's well that's.
Maybe you don't,
but if you do,
I'd fuck you out.
When you have these people that want to
get ahold of you,
you don't run.
I'm not saying run.
I'm saying like,
what are you guys looking for?
Like you,
they're going to just sit you down and
ask you questions for two days because
you put together this idea that somehow
or another there's some sort of an
international collaboration deal with
the threat of million life.
No,
they,
they looked at it.
They didn't know they thought I was at
snowden.
They thought I was.
They thought there was a group of people
leaking classified information.
They didn't know that you're from blink
one 82.
They didn't know that you like a huge.
They don't care about rockstar.
That's what they don't understand.
They don't care about who I am,
they just care about the material.
Right.
But it should take them like three
seconds to realize you're not Edward
Snowden,
you're a rockstar.
But I,
but I'm saying some pretty provocative
shit.
You got to realize no one else has
gone up there and talked about,
you know.
Once again,
I,
I'm in a tricky spot right now because a
lot of what happened back then,
you know,
I can't really get into now because of
the positions and the things I'm
involved with,
but read the book.
And so it was just because you printed
this stuff in the book that they wanted
to pull you aside and talk to you about
this for two days.
And I was all over radio and talking
about it and I was saying some other
crazy shit that I can't repeat.
So people listening,
if they want to go back and look at
those interviews,
that's a better way to.
Okay.
So you had said something in those
interviews that you can't say again
because they told you to stop talking
about it.
Absolutely,
yeah.
They tell you to stop talking about the
fact that you can't talk about it.
No,
I mean,
I don't think that's the issue.
They,
the more of the issue was what are you
trying to achieve?
And once they found out who I was
working with,
they were like,
Holy Shit.
And they only found that out when
wikileaks broke into John Podesta's
emails in my.
I was having video conferences and
conference calls with,
uh,
he was Obama's senior advisor at the
time.
So the Wall Street Journal broke the
story.
Like,
what's this rock star talking about Ufos
with Hillary.
Hillary Clinton's campaign manager,
no,
he was Obama's senior advisor so I had
nothing to do with Hillary,
you know,
so we were setting these up and when
that broke I had to call up my partner
from the CIA and I said,
you know,
I got to say,
I know I got no,
I can talk to you a little bit more
about who these people are.
And um,
and that's where I gained a really large
amount of credibility with them,
but also where they realized that we got
to figure out a better way to do this
and what you see is me and some very
important people coming together to do
something that I think is really
beneficial to society.
But a lot we have a lot of work to do
because a lot of people think they don't
know what to think of it.
At first they thought I was nuts when I
was talking about my book.
I'm all,
Oh God,
these advisors,
you know.
And then all of a sudden the Wall Street
Journal broke this story and there's all
these multi star generals and head of
some really big aerospace companies.
And then,
then the big news organizations were
like,
Holy Shit,
this is,
this might be real.
A lot of kids still don't know and
they're having fun on the Internet.
Um,
and then I came out a couple of weeks
ago on stage with all these people.
Now it's like now all the big huge.
I'm dealing with some crazy big
mainstream press that,
that we're trying to keep at bay for a
variety of reasons.
Um,
but yes,
it's all true.
And what to the stars is really after is
how do we,
how do we bring the public in on this
and work together to,
to communicate and educate this stuff.
How do we bring the technology out of
the shadows and build it for the world?
Um,
and how do we,
uh,
you know,
tell the story in documentaries,
nonfiction,
fictional works over a period of years.
And if we do that,
the public owns it.
The public has a say,
they're a part of it.
And then people will start to understand
over time why they did what they did.
They didn't lie to people,
uh,
just out of like ego.
It's they are like,
okay,
there's this group called Isis and
they're here and we need to understand
them and we need to fucking figure it
out quick.
Uh,
but the problem is these are
extraordinarily advanced civilizations
that have been coming here forever.
That's why it's all in all the ancient
fucking scripts and texts and carved
into the rocks and all that shit.
Um,
but trying to figure it out,
trying to connect the dots and trying
to.
I mean looking at debris that they
probably still have in a warehouse
going,
we have no fucking clue how to,
how to make this or back engineer this
stuff.
I mean there's a piece of metal from a
crash that I've seen and I've seen the
science on it and it's,
it's so it's atomically aligned and it's
layered and multi,
like 80 layers within just a few microns
of purities of metal that,
that aren't even in our solar system.
And they think it needs to be made in,
in an area where there's no gravity.
So number one,
it has to be made in space.
Number two,
even if we were to create a machine that
can potentially do some of this stuff,
three d printing layers of different
metals that have obscene purities,
it would cost hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars.
We don't even have that.
Why did they think it was made without
gravity?
Because,
uh,
I think it's the atomic structure.
So what happens is,
is when you radiate it with Terahertz,
it loses mass,
something weird,
it resonates,
some kind of harmonic and then it gets
lighter and if you hit it with enough
terahertz,
it'll float.
So we're going to be showing people this
stuff.
We're going to be bringing out the
hardware.
Some of the hard work will be bringing
out implants that are going to be
bringing up videos.
We're going to be bringing in showing
people this actual physical piece of
metal that was constructed in a zero
gravity environment and space.
And if you hit it with enough energy,
it becomes weightless.
Now,
I wouldn't say wait list.
I don't know if we can make enough
energy to do that.
But yes,
that is our plan in not only show the
experiment.
So if you can't give it enough energy to
make it weightless,
can you give it enough energy to reduce
the mass?
Yes.
So it weighs less.
And you can prove this.
Yes.
And that's why I didn't have a scale.
And you can put this piece of do scale.
I'll do you better.
It's not,
it's not even that.
It's warping the space time continuum
around the objects.
So you shoot.
What you can do is you can shoot an
electron over it.
Why?
It's why it's not a single electron and
you collect it in time that how do you
shoot a single electron final?
I'm not physicists.
They just do this shit.
That's what they do.
So.
And I was actually on a phone call today
about it.
I talked for about 45 minutes in the car
on the way up here about some of the,
some of the.
How would they even be able to regulate
whether or not they have a single
electron will do.
Fuck.
They're doing crazier shit than that at
cern.
At cern,
they're taking particles of atoms and
they're speeding them up to light speed.
Almost lights.
Yeah.
And slamming them into each other.
So I'm not too worried about electron
electrons and photons.
Ms Dot building.
That's,
I think it's sirens like 10 miles in the
lab.
Have you seen an electron microscope?
Right.
It's like the size of half of this too,
but I'm saying they're launching a
single electron at this thing.
I think that's what they do.
Yeah,
they do that with photons too,
by the way.
I read,
I read a really cool study about single
photons and consciousness was
interacting with it.
Just just by thinking it was changing
the way the photon went.
It's crazy.
So what happens is,
is you shoot this electron and you know
how fast it is to travel over this piece
of metal.
Then you,
then you radiate it with terahertz and
then you shouldn't mean radiated with
time.
You're,
you're your electrifying and charging
the piece of material noted terahertz.
It's,
it's a,
it's a high frequency wave.
I don't want to pretend I know that much
about it.
I just know that the earlier tests were
with radio waves like rf and uh,
and they need to do terahertz.
So I,
I don't know much more than that,
so and so by radio,
by shooting terahertz at it,
the piece of metal can lose mass and
then when you shoot an electron over it,
it'll be a different time than the other
one when it's not turned on.
Does that make sense?
No.
The time it takes for an electron to go
over the piece of metal.
What's that?
Jamie's been terahertz imaging,
laser guided codes,
advanced single pixel tele terahertz
imagery,
and this be the images sampled upon
instructions from a laser,
a the terahertz light passes through the
object and then see the information is
collected to reconstruct the image.
Look at that.
So with this stuff,
just an imaging technique,
you're timing how fast it takes an
electron to move over the surface of the
metal.
Then you charge the metal and then your
timing the exact same thing and there
will be different times and the positive
result is that it lost mass so it
traveled faster or slow or whatever the
hell is supposed to happen.
So,
and so I would imagine that this,
just this piece of metal,
if it exists,
would be kind of game over if you
brought this piece of metal to the most
advanced scientists and metallurgy or
whatever they would be that would
understand this kind of shit.
Yeah.
And it had already been there.
But the problem is,
is there anywhere online where people
can read about this,
there actually is.
There's some,
some of this stuff,
not this piece in particular that came
out as arts parts on arts bell a long
time ago and there are different layers
of business and magnesium.
But I uh,
but this one came from a crash in 48,
not 47 and I know nothing more about it,
but I don't think it's anything that can
come in here with the chain of custody
and say this came from air force or
something like that.
You know,
I don't know who has this.
So you're going to bring this and
demonstrate this to people.
Yeah.
And the reason is,
is because we need to.
We're also going to show,
um,
videos that just got declassified from
our most advanced systems,
I think they call it the Aegis Aegis
system.
It's a radar system and forward looking
for red of Ufo is have those in
possession
actually already.
And so we're going to show the videos
that just,
I mean the first time in history,
by the way,
that videos of Ufo iphones have been
declassified.
There's been leaks and there has been
people catching shit on their phones,
but I have all the chain of custody,
all the documents and everything and we
just got those a few weeks ago and
there's a shitload more common.
And so we'll release the videos and
we'll show the experiment as a proof of
concept.
So everyone knows the shits all rail
because right now they're just looking
at a drawing and they're looking at this
guy from the skunk works,
you know,
and just going,
how the fuck are they going to build a
machine that plays with time and plays
with the fabric of space time.
And so we have to kind of educate people
and say it's possible.
It's possible.
And yeah,
that's it.
They're advanced electro gravitt.
Gravitic propulsion is that.
I say that electrogravitics gravitic.
So what that does,
what the machine does that we're
building is there's A.
There's an electromagnetic wave that is
the foundation of everything,
of all mass,
of everything.
Like it's.
Some people call it zero point energy,
some people call it a the vacuum energy,
but like one inch of air could power the
United States for like hundreds of years
kind of thing or maybe more.
So what they got to do is isolate very
specific atoms to where all the noise of
all matter and cell phones and
everything that's going on on earth can
be,
can be separated from this one Adam.
And if you can do that with the right
material,
you can get access to that
electromagnetic wave that's powering the
atom,
the,
the invisible wave pattern that that's
under everything of all existence.
And once you do that,
it's not like splitting an atom.
This is the power behind the atom.
It's extraordinarily dangerous,
but it's also what will turn that thing
on and it'll turn into a ball of light
and just disappear.
And I could show you a video of,
of something doing that that's actually
on youtube,
you know,
told me what it is.
Who Goal I would.
I would have to,
I could search it for a second.
How about this?
Well,
there's no commercial breaks.
Is there?
No.
Oh fuck.
Just search it up.
I'll just describe it.
You know what,
if you type in,
um,
Astra,
uh,
the tr three,
be astro,
tr three B
and I'll walk over there and walk over
there for a second show in which one is.
Yes,
go ahead.
Gone to so we can all talk to each
other.
So what you want to do is come down here
and do your people get to a.
there'll be able to see it.
We'll put it up on the screen.
So what,
what?
This is
why I don't really want to tell you what
it is.
What I want you to watch it.
I'll find it for you.
Just takes me a second.
There's a bunch of bullshit.
This is the craft by the way.
And if you spell it right,
astro,
that's why.
Sorry.
Astra Astra.
Not Astro.
You're typing in at home.
He's got to get.
We got to get me.
Sure.
It's the right one.
We're looking on youtube.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you're in your car right now,
going,
what the fuck is going on in this show?
Most the vast majority of the people
just listened to this show.
So for the people that are just
listening and you want to go check it
out,
t are 38,
Astra Aurora project through s a f o
three b.
sorry.
This is the craft in secret machines,
but that's all I'm going to say.
This thing is floating in the air.
It'll take a few seconds till they turn
on the engine.
Well,
it looks pretty bad ass.
I don't wait.
You can see little lights dancing around
on the bottom,
but I think this was leaked on purpose
because the guy's making a just hard
enough to see moving the camera around
in and out of focus.
It's got like he's barely focusing soy.
That looks like a drone.
Well,
it looks small to.
It's not.
It's pretty big.
I would think that one's about 40 feet.
Really?
Look,
see the tail fins on the back.
That's how you know it's not alien per
se.
It's built off.
I think technology that came from there,
but you know,
they don't need vertical tail.
Stabilize that big light.
Okay.
This is the engine they turn it on.
So right now they're at.
They're accessing that energy I told you
about now and watch what happens.
It's gone.
There's a pilot in that.
If that was in a movie,
I'd want my money back.
This movie can suck my Dick.
Why?
Like so fake.
Oh that don't look fate.
What does that tr three beers.
These ones,
the other ones are the same one,
but these ones are stacked and that's a
drone that came out of one.
That's a drone.
The small one is have the little thing
that came out the side.
Yeah,
but if you.
You can look up black triangle Ufo and
find hundreds of these videos.
So these are a people look civilians
that are getting this from the ground
filming this.
I don't know.
I don't know where this one came.
One came from.
This is not the same account as the last
video.
Different video ended up next because
it's probably a tr three wii video.
How many views is out $474,000.
Now there's sundry.
There's so many people know now.
There's hundreds of these out there,
but what separates from the other one?
But everyone thinks everyone thinks I'm
it's alien and that's not my belief.
So you think this is something along the
lines,
like when they had the stealth bomber
program,
they were experimenting with these
things.
What do you think of Robert Lazaro?
Do you think that guy's real?
I'm putting out his autobiography.
So you do think he's legit and you
should read his book?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
He's a fascinating character,
right?
He is.
His story is really interesting to where
he really fucked up though.
So for the people that don't know that
are listening,
he's a guy that came out.
He's the reason we know about area 51.
He literally is,
is,
is the guy that broke the story of its
existence.
He got brought in for a job and that
during the they said we have another
idea for you,
and they put them in a,
a place he claims had all these disks
and he was on a back engineering team as
a physicist.
Um,
but what happened was they rushed him in
there because per his story,
they tried to cut into one of the
propulsion devices and it exploded and
killed a bunch of scientists.
So the Nevada test site,
which is the area where area 51 and all
that stuff is released a statement that
they were just doing a small little nuke
test,
but it was really because of this thing.
And so they rushed him in there without
doing all of his background checks
because it takes six months to a year.
And,
uh,
during those background checks,
he was already working on this stuff.
They,
um,
they found that his wife was going a
little haywire because he couldn't tell
her what she was,
what he was doing.
And he would leave in the middle of the
night.
He'd be gone for a week and she was
getting fed up.
And so she started having an affair and
so they're listening in all the phone
calls and checking them out and I kind
of go on his home.
Life is unstable,
so they stopped calling him to come into
work while they figure it out.
He knows.
I mean he's working next to a guy with a
machine gun.
He knows that,
uh,
that this is no fucking joke.
It no one knows what he's been doing.
And he thought he did something wrong.
So as the nervous individual he is,
he runs to his friends and says,
this is what I've been doing.
This is what I've been working on.
There's alien craft.
It's over here at groom lake.
And the tests are every Wednesday night
at 8:00.
And his wife goes,
Holy Shit.
And his friend goes,
And he goes,
come on,
I'll show you.
It's,
they drive three hours north of Vegas,
outs on public land.
And they videotape and watch these ufos
come up and be tested and dart around
and disappear.
And he goes,
that's the one I'm working on.
And it's almost like,
well,
how did you know what time?
Because I'm working on it,
well,
he does this three times.
I think it was three times and on the
third time they got caught because
there's,
I've been there,
there's security that,
that travels those mountains.
You always hear about those guys out
there and area 51,
when they caught him,
they were like,
holy fuck.
He's.
He's like,
what the fuck is he doing?
You know,
why is he telling everything?
So he runs to the new station with
George Knapp who another,
another,
um,
he's a host on coast to coast and he
tells him what he's doing and he just
goes live on Las Vegas news and it
caught like wildfire fire,
uh,
across the world.
And so then these guys grabbed him,
put him in a room,
put a gun to his head and said,
when we told you not to say anything,
we didn't mean say everything,
you know.
And uh,
he got really scared.
They started fucking with them.
I was actually at a meeting two nights
ago talking about some of the things
they did.
One of the things he did,
he went to a gym he used to.
He didn't have access to a lot of guns,
but if for some fucking reason he had
like an Uzi,
it was in his glove compartment.
He goes to a gym and he comes out and
his car doors are open,
the glove compartment is open,
and the Uzi just sitting on his chair,
he got a,
he got shot out on the freeway and they
erased a bunch of his records.
Uh,
and he still to this day really nervous
about it.
He,
he always claimed he put for a while.
He claimed he had,
part of this is what I will say.
He claimed the energy source was an
element that was very heavy and it was
like on a pentium or something like
that.
One 15 element and a 25 years ago he
talked
all about it.
He's.
And then literally three years ago,
maybe four,
they added it to the periodic table.
What is this stuff called again?
I think it's called underpin am.
It's one element.
One 15.
It's on.
And that's the other thing is people
don't realize,
Holy Shit,
25 years ago,
he says,
this element comes from a binary star
system and it's really heavy.
There's a certain isotope that stable,
they'll find it.
And then all of a sudden,
I remember one day I was driving my car
and I heard it like on CNN new element
added to the periodic table.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
you know.
But it's pretty interesting.
Crazy story.
Well,
they erased his history.
What is the claim that he had raised his
educational record?
Well,
I think he might have people.
I don't know if I think this is,
I don't even,
I don't know,
I never researched it,
but people that I know that have
researched,
I think he might have kind of upgraded
his residence,
his resume a little bit and maybe he
didn't go to mit.
That was the claim.
But they also said that he really did
work for a.
what's that
New Mexico?
Uh,
well,
Lawrence livermore and jpl.
Jpl,
jpl in Pasadena.
Yeah.
But,
well,
whatever it was,
it was in New Mexico that they had found
that he actually did work in the
building even though they tried to say
that he didn't.
Oh yeah.
Maybe I did something with somebody and
however much of his store was true,
always gets fishy when you find one
thing that's not true like that he
didn't go to mit and Freedom Stanton,
Stanton Friedman,
who's a very famous UFO researcher.
He's one of the main guys arguing that
Bob was ours full of Shit.
Yeah.
You know,
what's interesting is there is,
there is a,
um,
I know that guy that did all the
research on that and I know that guy
that studied it for decades and uh,
he's actually writing a forward on the
book.
It's the journalist has one like eight
peabody awards and Emmys and shit.
But uh,
George Knapp,
who I told you about and he's just got,
like,
he could speak for hours on that entire
funds on the coast to coast show,
right?
He doesn't like a couple Sundays each
month.
And I find that element.
What does it element 1:15,
is that what it's called?
Popular mechanics article about it.
Welcome element 1:15 now.
What's your real name?
Researchers create element 1:15,
the lab for the second time over the
first time over all in the first time in
a decade,
paving the way for its official status
as a member of the periodic table.
And so google,
Bob Lasar element 1:15 because I would
think that if he knew that like that
long ago,
like that alone would make people want
to take them more seriously.
All the stuff that he said.
Well first of all,
we know that there was a groom lake.
We know that there is an area 51 we know
they denied its existence and so they
wanted to expand the perimeter to till
they wanted to because people would sit
on a ledge and they would watch all
these test flights of whatever the fuck
they had.
Whatever it was they were doing,
whether working on stealth bombers,
whatever it was,
people would film this and so they
wanted to
expand the perimeter of prohibited area.
And so in doing so,
they had to admit the existence of the
base itself.
I believe that was in the nineties,
right?
Um,
it was in the nineties.
They expanded the perimeter.
Something else that the government had
to do is they had to admit you have
photos are real because there was a um,
some military people look at it.
Yeah.
He talks about 1:15 all through this
year.
This Jamie doesn't say the video on the
bottom.
What is it?
When was this put out?
This video?
Well,
this one is 2015,
but the video is taken on vhs.
Holy Fuck.
This is 1990.
Maybe it's on the Scifi channel.
Back when it was spelled Saifai.
Yeah.
Everyone uses a lot.
That's why f Y.
Yeah.
That's old as fuck.
Played some of that though,
because that dude's a trip because he's
one of those weird guys where if you're,
even,
if you're a skeptical guy,
you listen to bibles are talking like
sky is obviously smart as fuck.
Here we go in the top of the reactor,
and the base of the reactor apparently
is
something similar to a cyclotron.
If the particle accelerator a,
a particle is accelerated the high speed
and then deflect it up a small tube and
it's aimed at the 1:15,
this transmute the 1:15.
Uh,
similar to the way we do that in a
normal particle accelerator,
this causes a reaction or radiation
emission that we really haven't seen
before.
Um,
it produces annie matter.
This Annie matter is guided down,
attuned to,
and reacts with a gap
when matter in any matter,
react,
they convert to 100 percent energy.
This energy is converted,
heat energy is converted to electrical
power,
and the reactor itself.
This was done through a
thermoelectric converting.
And this electrical power is used to
power other subsystems on the craft.
Though there is no wiring as we would
know it also.
That's almost a byproduct of the
reactor.
The reactor also sets up a gravitational
wave from the 1:15 being bombarded this
gravitational wave,
it was present at the top of the reactor
and it is essentially guided in the same
way microwaves are guided through tune
tubes and uh,
this goes to and they're amplifying
cavities and through the projectors that
are in the bottom of the crap.
God,
I wish I was smart enough to know
whether he's full of Shit.
Well,
so what he's saying is that there's a
gravity wave that's accessible on,
on a really large element that extends
beyond the perimeter of the atom.
And when you bombard that,
that element with one particle Kinda
like what we were talking about before,
it goes through a tube,
like a very tiny miniature cern cern's
like a big magnet holds a particle in a
very specific
spot at hovers.
It shoots and it hits that.
It decays,
it becomes this matter anti matter
reaction,
uh,
these generators can convert all that
energy into power and then they can
amplify that wave that's coming off and
emanating from that element.
And they amplify it like you would
amplify or a radio wave.
Now there's no wires in the craft
because most likely it was three d
printed.
We didn't know about three d printing
back then.
I've talked to Bob about this,
but not just three d,
three d printing,
you know,
just the materials.
But atomically aligning the elements.
So.
So consciousness and other types of
things can move through those materials
to operate the craft.
It's really good
operating it without buttons.
Right.
Operating it.
So that was theoretically he said
theoretically,
right?
Yeah.
Was that there was handprints and that,
you know,
they were much different shaped hands
and ours in this craft that he had found
inside one of these bays and area 51,
he realized very quickly that it wasn't
something that we had created and that
it was somehow another powered through
intention.
Yep.
That would go through like touch or feel
or or put their hands would be on this
thing and consciously you would somehow
or another control all the various
aspects of this machine.
Exactly,
exactly.
Alright.
Sounds good.
Doesn't it?
I believe so hard.
Well,
I hope you do because was going to be,
there's going to be a lot of stuff.
I want to know what you've seen though.
So you've seen this piece of metal.
What else have you seen?
I've seen many,
many documents on the studies of these
things and I've seen a lot of the
science associated with what the
technology is and what it does.
Like a,
I could show you if I fold up pieces of
paper and stuff,
what's going on with it,
but basically,
uh,
you know,
these craft know when they travel in a
straight line,
but they're folding space type in event
horizon where they explain it by folding
a piece of paper and punching a pencil
through it.
You ever see that moment?
Yeah,
it's kind of like that movie,
but it's more like,
um,
you know,
here I can draw it for you here.
Not that this is a,
it's Kinda like when you have two
points,
um,
you know,
we're used to traveling in a direction
like that.
And so when we look up,
we see a plane that goes straight,
right?
But these,
these Ufos fold space time like this,
uh,
and so it looks like to them they're
going in a straight line.
So if you're in the ship you see that.
But if you're on the ground you see
that.
That's why you see them blink off and
on.
A lot of those videos they're on the,
it looks like they're jumping.
It's just because of this.
So having space time,
some way of interfacing with space
itself,
that's very different than our idea of
traveling in a linear way from point a
to point b
space.
The fabric,
they call it the fabric of space time
because it's like a fabric.
It's malleable.
Now,
let me ask you this.
How often into a conversation do people
look at you and think you are fucking
crazy when you started talking about
this and how long was the time?
All the time.
Right?
But do you ever get to the point where
like,
I don't want to talk about this because
it's you.
I always tell me,
you don't know what I know and there's a
lot.
No,
no.
I mean like,
do you ever get to the point where
you're like,
I can't do this anymore.
Now people think I'm fucking crazy now
because I'm involved on the most
important shit I've ever been in my
life.
So I think this is like the most
important thing that you've ever done.
Fuck yeah.
Like I,
I have meetings with senators coming up,
like,
oh fuck yeah,
senator.
So I can't tell you Dan was all this.
I can't tell you stuff.
I know this is some fucking Trenton.
When is all this going to come out?
Like it seems like this is like a
animate eminent rather disclosure type
shit.
Watch what my company does.
That's what I'll say.
So what is your company?
What are you,
what are you trying to do?
Well,
we created.
So if you look at the people involved,
uh,
we have senior high.
When you get to the senior levels of
government,
you're either called an sts or six
senior intelligence service,
senior executive service,
or you're a brass.
But either way the civilians have the
same kind of ranking charter that the
breast is.
So scs three,
ss three,
one three would be the same thing as a
three star general.
So I,
that's,
that's who these people are around me.
So I had the head of the skunkworks
engineering.
Um,
I got,
you know,
a to star from the clandestine director,
head of operations.
I have a guy under secretary of
intelligence for the Senate Intelligence
Committee and was.
These guys are retired that croissants.
Retard calls are recorded.
Well,
they all,
they all left.
They are currently life.
They now are involved the way you're
doing,
the way they are current consultants to
the Internet,
the intelligence community.
Okay.
That's probably the men involved in this
project with clearance.
They all have their top secret SSC.
I clearances.
Yeah.
I'm the only one that does it on my
entire team.
I'm the only one that does it.
Actually,
Lou that just came out,
I hired him away.
So he was head of all,
uh,
he was in charge of all classified,
operations for secretary of Defense
Mattis.
So he was what's called a gs 15 right
underneath the one,
two and three stars.
He ran the advanced aerial fet program.
And it's still continuing to this day
and he's with us now.
So the advanced aerial threat program
under the United States government is
essentially a Ufo.
That's one of the minimization gathering
assessment,
assessment of all of the,
of what those machines are doing that
gives off all these types of effects
that people are witnessing.
But there's also a very large group of
people that have had within government
that I've had close contact like
hundreds and it's connected to my group
and there's just more coming in that
way.
So that program is trying to figure out
what those technologies did to those
people and how those technologies work.
Even though it's
more saddle,
it's more about tasking,
you know,
our assets like satellites and other
things to be able to find these things
better.
But this is different than the secret
machines book,
which is more of another thing also.
Is there communication between the
United States government and alien
lifeforms?
I,
I personally,
I mean,
I don't know any of this stuff,
uh,
because I'm not invited to those types
of meetings.
But I personally wouldn't doubt it.
Yeah,
you wouldn't doubt it,
but they've never alluded to it or
discussed it with you in any way.
Not the,
not this group of people know.
Is there any speculation as to what
they're doing?
Resource extraction,
resource extraction,
like are like minerals,
empire building.
I tell people that.
Are the eggs the.
No,
I think it's changed.
I think it's Tacos think,
well,
you know,
they're here for the same reason I am,
but uh,
um,
I tell people like a good way to look at
this is like,
look at Syria and Syria is in chaos
because the United States and Russia are
having a proxy war there.
Now look at the earth.
It's the exact same thing.
Different races are coming here and uh,
and they're trying to win.
And one the universe we're talking
about.
I don't know how many,
I don't know,
but there's a bunch of different
creatures and they all have the same
sort of technology on summer.
Very human.
Some are looked just like you and I
really.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
No.
Is there any sort of speculation as to
why life forms from other planets,
other galaxies of the solar systems,
different kind of gravity,
different environments would create a
life form that's exactly similar to us
or are they imitating what we look like
in order to infiltrate our world and
hang with us?
I think probably all knowing.
I think all the above.
I mean,
look,
if you look at,
if you look at Syria or are you just
going to say it's only Russia and
America,
they're trying is probably there,
Francis probably there,
you know?
Um,
I,
I personally think the little,
the little aliens with the big black
eyes,
those are androids,
their biological robots.
They're just programmed.
There's no different than us cloning
sheep.
They just clone a being that can travel
through space because space is sort of
artificial intelligence thing that
doesn't have a life form.
Right.
I heard that idea before and it Kinda
kinda makes sense a little bit,
right?
I mean,
if,
if you're a living thing and you're
traveling through space,
obviously a biological limitations in
terms of the need for oxygen and
gravitational interactions and all these
different things that one of the
scariest hallmarks of those ones,
the room or is it in the back of their
head as a transmitter?
So you gotta wonder where it's sending
shit,
but at the same time,
you know,
I can tell you that when you look at the
Bible,
uh,
the angels and the demons of the Bible
would be the humans and the androids
that I just told you about.
So you think the grades of the Androids,
right?
So you think there like some sort of
devil?
No,
I just think that that's how we
characterized it because they come in
and control your thoughts.
Control your body.
Take is in the middle of the night.
Yeah.
Demons,
you know.
Um,
so
do you think these things are traveling
from where?
Do we have any idea?
There's things that have been put out
there,
but I've never asked.
Why would you not ask them what the
fuck?
He didn't tell me.
Star system like four,
eight,
three,
and I'll be know about element 1:15.
I would want to know about star ship
enterprise coordinate 1:15,
nine,
six,
five polaris.
Wherever the fuck it is.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
I do know that there's,
there's connections to um,
you know,
you won't even fucking believe it.
I'll tell you that.
You want to please Atlantis,
Atlantis,
the sunken city.
Yeah.
There's a connection.
What the connection that there is a very
advanced group that left after a
catastrophe and hung around in a small
outpost here and throughout time would
push civilization forward and not to the
Greek gods were.
Whoa.
Yep.
And that's why it's very interesting
when the Roswell records,
there's Greek writing is there,
there is,
I've never seen any of the records from
Roswell view.
It's online.
You just type in Roswell records.
You can see it.
We're seen as the dude standing in front
of the bullshit,
the weather balloon stuff,
or they'll laugh and yucking it up.
Roswell wreckage,
Roswell,
IBM,
you'll see it.
And,
uh,
and it's got these Greek markings and
the witnesses that were there did,
um,
did,
uh,
what do you call it?
A where they go on a site on earth
until,
so that actual IBM showing the word l
love Fieri,
uh,
which means freedom in ancient Greek.
So ism from Jamie.
Let me tell you why he want me to.
I don't know if popped up when it,
when.
Well,
I'm going to tell you something else.
So I went and met.
I'm a former director of CIA and NSA.
He was director of both.
I want to tell you his name and right
when I sat down and told them about my
book,
pull the picture up again,
literally his little hands.
And right when I sat down and told him
about my,
you gotta this is a big deal.
I wouldn't have everything.
So I'm sitting with this guy.
He was like not that long ago.
Was Director of CIA and he went on to be
director of NSA.
Okay.
Well,
I think we can find his name maybe,
but uh,
right when I sat down and told them
about the book,
you know what he says to me,
what he goes,
I didn't read much science fiction as a
kid,
but I read a lot about Greek mythology
and looked me in the.
I said,
well,
you're going to love the last page of my
book then he's all man.
And uh,
uh,
when my book was about ready to go to
pressing,
I had a very important person call me
up.
He says,
can you stop that pressing and maybe
insert something about Greek mythology?
And I said,
I sure can.
So once,
something you got to realize is,
for example,
the sixth biggest defense contractor in
the world,
at least they used to be six.
There's a company called Science
Applications International Corporation,
let's say.
I see their headquarters are actually in
San Diego and in the front of the
building you have a,
um,
an oblique coming out of a fake lake and
two,
um,
Atlantean on thrones and they're both
holding pyramids and one says the past
and the future.
It's in there.
Eight foot tall statues.
It's fucking nuts by the way.
An essay.
I see.
They just,
they went over to Leidos.
Michael Hayden,
the former director of NSA and the CIA.
What about it?
No,
that's not him,
but I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna.
Tell you if you try and find out what.
Can you guys just fishing around?
I'll say a name.
You Blink.
I'll show you my.
No Pun intended.
That was cute.
I'll show you my dick.
Like,
no way.
Yeah,
here we go.
If you,
if you are not sure what.
Yeah,
whatever you get.
I'm going to show you my dick.
What do you think about all that
Zechariah?
Search and stuff?
I think he was close.
I don't think he was exact,
but it's interpretive.
You know,
if I was to show you some symbols for
people who don't know what that is
exactly what I is,
a is a Palestinian scholar that decoded
a lot of ancient Sumerian texts that
were written in Acadian.
I'm Samira was like kind of the first
civilization that was advanced that we
even know of just out of nowhere here,
like 3,500 years before Christ.
There's mathematics,
astronomy and all this different shit.
They knew all the planets.
They said there was an extra planet,
but Zacharias was the.
Was the one that really spent a lot of
time doing that.
And there's,
there's a lot of other scholars that
disagree now he can say,
you know,
in those texts is the,
is the story of the garden of Eden,
the flood of Noah,
like all that shit.
But his take on it was those who from
heaven to earth came called the main
jewels,
but they were an advanced race.
They fucked around with genetics.
Well that was the,
his take on the definition of Nephilim
was the.
Was the nephew.
Yeah.
What you find them.
You find that in genesis,
the Nephilim.
So,
you know,
he,
he was able to tell a really interesting
story based on these texts and um,
but some people don't agree with them,
but at the,
at the end of the day,
I think it's the closest thing we got.
And in my early conversations when I
was,
when I was being given some interesting
science fiction stuff for my book,
uh,
the Greek mythology part,
I brought up the Sumerians and they
showed me one particular king.
They said this,
we find this one very interesting and I
can't remember his name,
but it fired so quick when I asked the
question.
It came right back with this whole thing
on this one,
Sumerian king.
Really interesting.
Well,
what's fascinating about them is that
they really did know a lot about our
solar system.
Can you think about the fact that they
were around 5,000 years ago,
they had a detailed model of the solar
system with all of the planets and they
were all relatively close in size.
This is a clay,
one of those clay cylinders that you
would.
What you would do is you would put out a
flat piece of clay and you would roll
this cylinder over it and that's how
they would print things.
Yep.
And this and this really sort of kind of
primitive way of doing this.
Somehow or another,
they knew a lot about astronomy.
I mean,
they knew about the structure of our
solar system.
They knew where the planets were,
right?
Well,
you gotta remember Galileo was almost
killed and confined to his house house
arrest because he said that the
universe doesn't revolve around us.
We revolve around the sun and that was
way after.
That's for 5,000 years after the
seminarians that already knew that,
you know,
we weren't the center of the universe.
So it's interesting.
We were really smart and then we went
backwards.
You know,
and there's probably a bit more to that
story too,
that hopefully one day we'll get into
it.
Well,
it's just,
it's really interesting when you look at
these ancient civilizations and their
attempts to decipher the world around
them and you try to figure out what did
they know?
You know,
how much did they know that the
Sumerians or one of the more interesting
cases to me,
because of the fact that they had this
really bizarre map of the solar system
when we didn't,
they,
they found out about Pluto.
They had a,
an image of Pluto and I don't think we
found out about Pluto until like the
early 19 hundreds.
Yeah.
The Pluto might've even been like 15 or
16.
You can find that out.
Pluto was found like,
like not even that long ago.
I don't know if it was as far back as
the night to see if you could find that
out and then find the image of the
Annunaki when they show the solar
system.
Because the image is really fascinating
because it is what it is.
I mean,
you look at it,
there's a son.
I mean it's clearly a son.
It has like a,
it's a large circle.
It's in the sky and it has those little
son sort of raise around this picture,
right?
Because yeah.
That's the picture.
There you go.
So do you know they,
they have an idea of where to look for
this extra planet.
They thought in the early nineties,
jpl announced that they thought they
found a companion to our son.
He'll look at that.
I mean that's fucking radical right
there.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
They have pluto in there now.
Go to the discovery of Pluto when we
went to Pluto,
get discovered.
I think you're right.
I think it wasn't the 19 fifties.
I know it was sometime in the 19th.
I'm talking about Disney's Pluto,
which means 30,
19,
30.
Crazy.
Crazy shit.
Yeah.
So these people somehow or another new
about Pluto fuck in way before us.
And this is not something you could see
with the naked eye.
So somehow or another and ignore where
there's other planets.
I mean you could see a few of them.
You could see Mars and sometimes you
could see Jupiter,
maybe Saturn,
right?
Saturn.
What are the ones you can see Saturn and
after that they had uranus.
You can't see.
It's just the other one.
Time have,
I don't know,
every 25 years you can barely see it
with the naked eye we were in last week
or something like that.
You were at Griffith Observatory.
It was like super crowded because of
that.
Or we're not gonna we're not gonna.
Make jokes and shit about your anus,
right?
No,
because it's so old.
Yeah.
And were they looking at it with the
naked eye or with telescope?
I feel like you could observed because
everyone goes there.
There's a bunch of telescopes already
set up,
but that makes sense for telescopes.
But why would the naked eye.
It's one of the best places closest to
la or I don't.
Yeah,
La is weird because of the light
pollution right now.
It's so it's a big deal.
That's why,
you know when you go to the desert and
it's beautiful and I'm like Whoa,
that's you releasing.
It was last week,
October
19th.
You could see with your naked eye that
urine,
the secret to a unit.
You guys are talking about naked in
Uranus.
A lot here and I don't want to make any
jokes.
I'm not,
but I'm just telling you what you're
talking about.
See your anus with your naked eye this
week.
Giggle if you must.
What a goofy name too.
Like what?
All the different sounds you can make
with your face and they chose your
buddle.
What if they just call it buddle?
Yeah.
Butthole planet butthole.
It'd be just as weird.
Fucking crazy.
Fast be the first place I go.
That would be the first place you've
visited the planet buddle?
Yeah.
Do you think that there's life in our
solar system?
I do.
Where do you think it is?
Europa?
Really?
So you think there's some sort of a
primitive life form that's under the
ice?
I think there's life on Mars and I think
it's a little start from.
I think there's life on Mars.
I think it's small little animals in
microbial or or insects shit that's kind
of learning how to live with it's
radioactive environment,
which by the way,
a bunch of scientists from jpl found
that there was some atomic weapons that
went off on Mars because the,
the,
the radioactive signature is can only
happen if you explode a nuclear weapon.
That's artificially made,
not like a,
like something that happens naturally,
like a moon exploding on the surface.
So it's interesting.
So you read that.
Oh Shit.
That's been all over the place.
I forgot the guy's name.
The doctor's name.
Um,
he's a,
he actually was one of the lead
scientists on a clementine mission which
was mapping the moon with jpl.
So he's a,
he's a big time dude.
And he thinks there was nuclear war.
Huge.
Well,
he doesn't say that.
He just says that nuclear weapons.
He just says we have this signature.
He all peer reviewed science that the
signature of the radioactive activity
from this very specific isotope that
only comes from artificial nuclear
explosion or something.
Shit,
I don't want to mess with something
along those lines.
Well,
I'd heard before that they thought that
somehow or another Mars was impacted
that something hit it like some sort of
Rasta oil impact and it destroyed the
environment.
I think it's the new,
if you type in nuclear weapon Mars or
nukes on Mars or some shit,
you'll find it.
You go to Richard Hoagland site,
Hoagland.
He kind of disappeared though.
Yeah.
That guy was wacky as fuck,
like he,
he was one of the WHO's the one of the
main proponents of the face on Mars and
all the pyramids that they found on
Mars.
They would find these weird connections
chain one point to another point and
somehow or another they made some
arbitrary distinctions that those were
indicative of intelligent design.
Elon musk wanted to drop nukes up there
too.
Good move.
Elan Musk elaborates proposal to nuke.
Maurice,
how's that?
Picture is not.
He's probably bored.
He put on his instagram last night.
He was a cooking hot dogs and
marshmallows and singing along with
Johnny cash drinking whiskey.
That's what he should be fucking
scientist.
Yeah.
That's Elon Musk for president.
I'll vote for you buddy.
Come on.
Let's do it.
Why don't you talk to him and he's
already got space x once you guys
collaborated.
The second thing we're doing,
he might really actually be interested
in.
And so the two aerospace projects to the
stars is doing.
One is we're building something that
will in effect be anti gravity,
but it's actually,
that's actually not the mechanism it
does.
Uh,
and building a spacecraft,
but the second thing that we're doing is
called beamed energy propulsion,
which is something I think musk will be
very interested in.
It's launching cubesats with lasers.
So,
uh,
the air force research lab kind of broke
the science back in the nineties and a
bunch of people associated with that
program got it declassified and they're
working for us on building it.
So it'll take a handful of years to do.
But what you do is you use very strong,
either microwaves or some other kind of
wave and it ignites and explodes the air
underneath a mechanism that carries a
cube set.
And so essentially what happens is,
is you don't use any fossil fuels and it
can bring the cost of launching a cube
sat from like 50 grand down to five
grand.
It's like crazy.
So that means colleges and neighbors and
anyone else can launch cube sats quite
easily.
Now,
have you had any debates with people
about this stuff?
If you ever like,
had someone who thinks that this is all
nonsense and sat down with you,
understands physics and understands
rocket propulsion space and elements.
And all that shit.
Um,
no I haven't.
I wouldn't be able to debate a
physicist,
but they can read all the papers.
Right.
But I mean,
is anybody been skeptical?
Zara.
But yeah,
everyone's skeptical.
Yeah.
And what's your response to that?
You don't know what I know,
right?
Well,
do you know though?
I don't know.
I can't tell you some of the shit that I
know and I can't tell you,
but what could it be that so crazy if
you,
you'd know.
I mean,
what you've said,
we'll think about what you've said.
You said that there's some ridiculous
sorta propulsion system that allows you
to move through time that they,
they visit this planet all the time and
extract resources that there's people in
the government that are trying to
disseminate this information,
but they don't know how to do it.
They don't have the right vehicle to do
it.
They're doing it in these sort of
controlled chunks.
Think of all these things that you've
said.
What could possibly be crazier than
that?
Well,
you're asking me how do I know and.
No,
no,
no.
I'm asking you,
what do you know that could possibly be
crazier than that?
Well,
like that's the Shit I can't tell you.
It's not.
Everything's Hunky Dory.
Is it something where you worried about
the fate of the human race?
I think that's part of it.
Where should I move?
I was going to move.
It's not existential.
If your dick out.
If I should go to Australia.
How about,
how about I just get down in Australia.
I mean where's the spot?
I don't think there is one
unfortunately.
Spot they just get this.
This is what I will say.
They're not existential in the sense of
they're not gonna come here like
independence day in nuke the place.
Um,
but it,
there,
you know,
there are things to worry about and
that's why I think
anybody that's famous,
that's an alien.
Oh,
I don't know.
Do you think there's any influential
figure that has been sort of shaping
culture that might not be one of us?
Oprah,
for sure.
It has to be Oprah.
Yeah.
If you go back to the early days
when Oprah says,
do that stupid show,
we should have like KKK members on and
everybody sat on white plastic seats.
Remember those days or that Geraldo?
Is that Oprah,
Oprah,
or early days?
Man,
me and Al Magical.
I'll never forget this.
It was like when I first met owl,
probably like late nineties,
I think we were in San Francisco doing
bong hits,
watching TV and oprah was on and it was
old oprah,
Oprah,
oprah might not have been the nineties,
might have been early 2000 of aliens
from men in black.
They were watching at the beginning,
remember?
Oh yeah.
You know,
I don't know.
I mean I,
uh,
again,
there's elements of this subject that
are,
that are disturbing and you know,
I don't think people need to know all
that shit.
So do you subscribe to the idea that
human beings are the product of genetic
engineering?
I do.
You do?
So you think that they took some lower
hominids and that they did something to
them to create human beings?
That is a very popular theory among Ufo
fanatics.
Or she'll say fans,
[inaudible] I,
I don't want to speak again for my
company,
but one of the people on our board,
a scientific,
they call it a scientific advisory
board,
is a lead geneticists from Stanford who
I think he was up for the Nobel this
year.
And what's his name?
Dr Gary Nolan.
And he will be the Jeanette.
He would be the guy to ask about that at
him in here.
But he,
but he's,
he's only going to tell you what's,
what,
what he can prove with science.
He's not going to speculate,
you know?
So what,
what makes people think that?
Like what's the science that makes
people think that?
Well,
there's a lot of junk DNA.
There's certain parts of our DNA that
seems to have been turned off.
There's,
there's a,
a bunch of things in there that we don't
understand and we don't have the leaps
of humanity over the past 5,000 years to
really show like where did,
what happened in the past 5,000 years
that wasn't happening for the hundreds
of millions of years before that.
They just found a footprint that was,
um,
like 100 million years old or something
like that.
That was just a human footprint.
What they did,
I just read the news,
I don't know.
I can't remember,
but it's like a fossil and now they're
like,
fuck,
this totally throws everything upside
down.
And talking to Sarah Pailin,
there was something to sell a pale and
said,
remember that like there was a librarian
that said that she,
she didn't believe that,
uh,
she was a young Earth creationist and
she thought that,
uh,
there was a picture online that showed a
human footprint inside of dinosaur
footprint that approved the people
walked dinosaurs.
I wouldn't doubt it.
I doubt that people walked with diamond.
Oh,
not at all.
I think there's been cycles of
civilizations and I think the people on
the inside know that.
And that's why at that defense
contractor,
multi,
multibillion dollar defense,
the ones that chose the government of
Iraq after we took over Iraq and the
ones that looked over after all of our
nukes,
hey,
look it there.
They have print inside of dinosaur
footprints.
She's right.
But they have,
um,
but they have at that place,
remember I told you they have the past
and the future with big pyramids in
their hands,
which regions,
you know,
that they're trying.
It's like,
it's a spooky
when you look at that and you believe
that the asteroid hit the Yucatan and
caused the mass extinction that killed
off most of the life on the planet.
I don't know.
I can't believe in it.
Fuck,
I've never studied that shit and I
wasn't there.
But I mean there's physical evidence for
that.
It's more like,
well,
yeah,
but I haven't read anything about it.
But sure.
I can believe in things.
I can't prove a lot of things,
you know?
Right.
But that's like the whole reason why
we're supposedly here that it killed off
the dinosaurs and allowed whatever they
think there was some sort of a mole,
mole type creature that evolved over 65
million years ago was bullshit.
I think it's all bullshit.
I think you think evolution bullshit?
Um,
no.
I think that at some point in history,
uh,
they came.
Someone came here and tampered with
existing creatures and made us an
upgraded us at very specific intervals
who tampered with them and what came
first,
the chicken or the egg.
You know what I'm saying?
Question.
Yeah.
I don't know.
A single celled organism.
We all kind of agree like that was like
the beginning,
right?
Most scientists,
not we,
I'm too stupid for this,
but obviously somehow or another that
became a bird,
right?
Why couldn't it become a monkey?
Why could that monkey become a person?
I think it,
yeah.
I don't know.
I mean look at evolution changes.
I mean we can,
we know that people that like beat their
kids,
their kids DNA changes based on getting
beat,
you know?
So when you were fighting,
you were changing people's DNA and
you're a geneticist,
you know,
you went after it for science,
that's why we were doing the fighting
for sure.
It's a lab coat on.
So if you,
if you think about it that way,
if you think about that all life somehow
or another continues to evolve and
advanced and through natural selection,
genetic mutation and random mutations
that things move from one stage of
existence to what they are today.
Right?
That when you look at,
you know,
a con or a hippopotamus that it used to
be something different and now it's
that.
Sure,
why wouldn't that be the case that
people too.
I think that is the case with people.
I just think that the quantum leaps in
our evolution,
our symptoms or effects of being
genetically upgraded.
The way I've heard it explained to me
though,
is that those,
the only leap that's really confusing is
the doubling of the human brain.
You got a big leap and so over the
period of 2 million years apparently,
obviously I'm too stupid to really
understand this,
but from what I've read,
what I've heard people talk about,
that's apparently one of the biggest
misses mysteries,
uh,
when it comes to the human fossil
record.
But there's a pretty clear line
apparently from Australia,
[inaudible] to,
you know,
to the homeless Judaism zig words on me.
Trying to pivot is not a big word like
it.
What the fuck is that stuff again?
Penis,
anus,
whatever.
That's called.
One 15,
1:15.
That's death on that stuff.
So what is your company aiming to do and
when are you trying to do it?
So the next steps.
So to the Stars Academy of Arts and
Science wise we have an academy because
people.
Yeah,
there's,
there's teaching,
there's science,
there's art major know there's film
franchises.
So what this doesn't say musicals,
know musicals,
right?
It's only musicals.
Musicals.
It's like everything is cool but not
really stupid art forum.
It's a,
it's a musical,
but it's very salacious.
Very,
very sexual musicals.
But okay.
So what we did essentially is you have a
senior engineer,
chief engineer from the classified
aerospace world building shit.
And then you have a guy like me that's
putting out some stories and making some
movies about some things.
And then you have my physicists.
Can I stop you there?
I'm sorry to interrupt,
but why stories and why fiction,
like why not just going to be both.
There's maybe both,
but why fiction?
Why not just concentrate entirely on
revealing the truth because it has to be
managed in a certain way for people to
understand and I think that someone's
sitting down and watching a debate play
out and having an idea of what,
what went on over the past 70 years.
They'll come out of that with an
emotional response and more of an
understanding and then want to go watch
the documentary and then want to buy
some of the nonfiction works that we've
done.
I've already put out,
um,
uh,
one of our nonfiction books with secret
machines.
Now the,
uh,
that movie.
What is it?
Arrival.
Yeah.
I was at the movie where there's like
sort of weird time shit in that movie.
Does that movie have any basis in
reality?
No.
Secret people behind the scenes?
No,
I don't think so.
But,
uh,
there's nothing in there that's familiar
to me other than the fact that the dream
sequences and the time stuff and her
having flashes of that shit's absolutely
on par.
And,
um,
the idea of having a,
an international group work together and
figure something out that's absolutely
on what's happening right now.
And everybody's keeping their mouth
shut.
Oh fuck you.
Why are they doing that?
Why aren't people spilling the beans?
Um,
well,
it's not every.
I mean,
look at Lou Elizondo,
the guy that works for me,
they just came from the Pentagon,
literally quit the Pentagon two weeks
ago.
I was the,
I can't tell you where I'm at,
but I know I'm sorry.
But,
um,
but,
uh,
he's with me and he,
he was onstage with me on the live event
we did on the 11 saying I left the
Pentagon days ago.
I ran this particular Ufo program and
this is what we know and they are real
and we're gonna continue that program
here at to the stars.
Now what's your.
So your goal is to release this
information through documentaries,
through films,
and educate people,
but the existence of this and is it to
make a ship?
What?
No.
So we're bringing.
So this is once again,
look there by putting together.
You can't attack this subject by just
like if you make a movie that's a crazy
movie.
If you make a science paper on it and
then no one's going to read it and the
technology will never see the light of
day because it's been modified as
weaponry or whatever it is that the only
way to get people to understand what the
fuck is going on is by first present
them the story so they have an
understanding that it is real and it
happening and laid in a way that's
grounded and practical and uh,
but still moves you and then follow up
with the science and then show them that
that thing you're watching in the movie
can be engineered and created.
So we're doing it all together.
But there's a thing called a community
of interest.
So to the stars is also building a
portal with the Department of Defense to
share information,
to educate people,
to put some declassified now
declassified videos of Ufo shows,
some science,
some documents,
and have open forums,
uh,
and have current military people talk to
young adults.
So you're gonna expose people to this
narrative and uh,
explained to them through stories what
this could be that sets the stage.
Then you start to introduce the actual
real elements that actually exist yet.
And then eventually what,
what's the end game will the end game is
to.
The technology itself is like.
So when,
when you make a,
when you,
when you create this energy source to
power the spacecraft,
it's called an over unity machine.
So it puts out more power than what's
put into it.
You can desalinate ocean water with it,
you can get rid of a atomic power.
So there's no radio,
no more Fukushima xeno.
It could do a lot of different things,
but it also will rapidly,
rapidly transform our entire
transportation and communication
network.
So the end result with that is it,
that'll get spun out into a accompany.
That's probably partners with major
aerospace organizations,
which with whom I'm already talking and
we partner on the madness.
You can't tell me who they are,
no,
fuck now I can't tell you and we bring
that out to the world,
but the only way that can be brought out
to the world as if the public owns it
and we build it from scratch.
The public was the public have to own it
because,
well I guess you could be in a way a
private person,
but the technology,
it probably has an element of what they
call eminent domain.
So we're going to get to a certain point
where certain agencies will probably
knock on our door and go,
what the fuck are you doing?
And we're going to say the public owns
this.
You can't take it from.
And they're gonna say fuck yeah,
we can take it and we're going to say
we're going to work something out
because it's like building a nuclear
bomb in your basement kind of thing.
So,
so when you say the public owns it,
like how will that be possible?
How would the,
how will the public own it?
The you can go to our,
we've,
we reserved a small amount of shares of
the company that people can buy stock in
the company right now.
So a year ago,
the success,
not the public.
That's private,
that's private ownership,
right?
If people buy the company can go public,
but no it didn't.
No,
it is public.
So a year and a half ago,
maybe 24 months ago,
the sec wanted to democratize,
um,
uh,
going public with companies just like an
IPO but not have to spend millions of
dollars and do it.
So they launched what's called a
regulation,
a direct public offering.
And we had a file with the SEC.
So we had to spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars to do this and we spent the
last six months doing it and our live
event
launch that.
So you can go to tennis.
Did this just so that you can tell the
whoever the fuck it is that will come
after you,
that hey,
the public owns this.
You can't take that.
That's one element of everything that
we're doing.
Yeah.
That.
So you're anticipate you're spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
anticipate someone coming in and closing
the doors and they yet you're talking
about it in advance.
We're like,
you're essentially telling,
strategizing that you know,
but you're letting them know that you
know,
that they're going to come and get it.
It'd be much harder to shut it down when
the whole world has paid for it,
invested in it,
owns it.
And uh,
so he trying to get people to buy
things.
I'm trying.
What do you mean you tried to get people
to buy stock?
Well,
yeah.
Right now we're a public.
You can buy shares of the company.
You can only.
We only put up.
I'm a very limited amount that we only
put it.
I think we only put up $5 million shares
or so.
That seems like a lot of shares.
How many shares are they're all others.
Oh Lord is like a 100 million probably
or something like 100.
How does that,
how does shares work?
Shares late.
You just don't work.
Like say if we,
uh,
came up with young Jamie incorporated.
Yeah.
And we wanted to start selling shares.
When you file as a corporation,
you can issue shares and you can sell
those shares to people in those shares.
Have a price based on,
you know,
how you want to value your company,
you know.
Okay.
So you could have like 100 million
shares of young Jamie Incorporated.
Yep.
You sure can.
Okay.
And so then the government can shut you
down,
Bro.
Nah.
Well you guys may be because you say a
lot of bad words.
No,
no,
no.
Jamie doesn't.
But I'm warming.
We do a lot at the company.
Right?
So we're building essentially a science
fiction version of Disney.
Okay.
So we have four film franchises.
Not all of them,
about Ufos.
One is kind of this blade runner night,
all about nightmares kind of thing.
One is like an old amblin.
Spielberg goes and making these things
a.
We are.
Let me know who's writing them.
I wrote the first one.
I'm directing that a good directing too.
I wrote this script and you're multi
talented motherfucker.
Look I'm,
that's where I'm going with most of this
stuff.
But the company I had to get up and get
going and set it up and we bring in a
ceo and all that kind of shit.
It's a bizarre formula,
right?
An entertainment company that's also
gonna do aerospace and science will.
The heart of it is when we do what's
called confirmation,
not disclosure confirmation.
A the heart of it is is how do we tell
stories that galvanized the human race
and let them know a little bit more
about what's going on and how do we
present them science so they understand
the consciousness and a lot of other
things are real.
And how do we build a technology
associated with those stories and with
dos science that can change the world.
And that's why it's an academy.
So they have any pickled bodies
anywhere.
I go from Ohio.
I believe they do believe they do.
Nobody's ever told you that I believe to
get.
I believe they do.
You believe they do?
You can't say anymore than.
I'm not gonna say anymore than that said
so much what you can and can't say.
Well,
I can tell you other shit offline.
Probably offline.
I can't wait to end this podcast.
Fucking kick me out.
I tell anybody please.
Some weird shit.
Um,
so now what,
what's
the timeline for moving forward with all
this stuff?
Okay.
So in the next few weeks we're going to
be releasing the first declassified
videos of these advanced aerial threat
Ufos,
um,
and they are current videos that were
just caught and with audio and
everything of the people tracking and
uh,
and we're going to launch the Beta
version of the community of interest,
which is the partnered website that's
going to be hosting all this
declassified information where we're
gonna be having the hardcore.
I'm a conversations with people that
want to understand this stuff.
We're going to be also doing an
experiment with that piece of metal to
show the world that the technology is
not only real,
but it's,
it's demonstrated and the videos are
very much a proof of concept,
you know,
it was showing you look at works,
so we're going to build it.
And um,
do you think it's gonna be weird for
people to take you seriously because
you're a rockstar like me.
If you were like some sort of a
physicist scientist that would listen to
you more.
Well,
you know,
I remember when Ellen came out years ago
and he started space x and then he
started test that.
My,
here's this dude saying all this
ambitious shit.
I didn't buy any of it.
I think guys a 100 times smarter than
the both of us combined.
The he's fucking gnarly.
I know,
but I'm just saying he caught believable
once a year maybe.
And maybe I think he is.
I mean,
shit,
he's bad ass.
But look at the people.
You know what's interesting to me is you
haven't seen who are with.
Have you looked at the bios on the shit?
No.
Yeah,
you got to read the Bios of the people.
I didn't want to be tainted.
I wanted to talk to one of the,
on my,
on my sat.
The Scientific Board Advisory Board is,
you know,
one of the guys that CIA that headed up
the entire biowarfare program and the
director of operations,
the client desk nine divisions.
All these guys have found us how various
ways.
So they've come to you because they like
the beacon.
I did something as this is the way to
go.
I did something that no one thought was
possible.
What's that?
Was tying together a mechanism that can
perpetually fund itself and can
communicate and can innovate all with
people that sit at the seat.
I created a round table with engineers,
scientists until high ranking
intelligence officials and uh,
and some others I can't tell you about
it,
obviously in the,
in the defense world,
it's called stove piping.
So when they,
when they compartmentalize a secret,
they put them into these vertical
categories that can't talk to each
other.
I created a horizontal structure where
all these people in these amazing
accomplished positions in government
were able to come together at the same
table and they can discuss what we want
to teach the world and how we want to do
that.
And,
but the but the way to do that is
including the public and making it a
public benefit corporation.
And what that means is we're able to
spend money and it's in our charter on
things that can benefit the world and
not just provide a return to the
investors,
but what we're doing happens to be
extremely lucrative,
lucrative,
my,
my engine,
lucrative for investors or insure
investors and the company.
So it was it like saved young.
Jamie wants to be a part of it.
What does,
what does he have to do?
You just go to the Stars Academy Dot Com
and you buy shares whatever you want to
buy.
And I will be lucrative for him because
the first of all the technology,
it sounds like a trillion dollar thing.
If we can figure that out over the next
eight years and they think we can.
So they.
Who's they?
The,
the engineers that are building this
thing.
The guy.
So Steve Justice that was head of
advanced programs at the skunk works.
We talked about that.
They build all of our.
They are the tip of the spear for the
most advanced spacecraft and aircraft
that the United States national security
apparatus has period,
period.
Hands down.
And he was the big boy there and their
model,
we think we have a s,
you know,
this is a,
this is a guest,
but I think there's a 60 percent chance
within 36 months or so,
we'll be able to demonstrate something
pretty kick ass and as long as there's
no major obstacle there,
we think within eight years we'll be
able to have something but it's
expensive and we've got to work with the
government and we're going to have to
work with major aerospace.
For example,
this one meeting I have coming up with,
with a big name aerospace company,
is offering their material sciences
division.
We need that.
We need to be able to create certain
metals that can resonate and circle
certain frequencies,
shit like that.
The other way that the company makes
money is when we build this,
the satellite launching system.
That's like exactly what [inaudible]
doing now putting satellites in orbit,
but we don't have to build rockets.
We can launch them with lasers.
That's a big deal.
You point lasers at the bottom of a cube
sat,
which is like the size of a shoe box,
and you can put it into low earth orbit
and you can put it up even higher
without using any fossil fuels with
using light.
That's a big deal.
That's a multibillion dollar gimmick
right there.
It's just been proven.
I told you,
seeing the proof.
There's this video of this accident.
It's in our launch video.
If you watch the video at the top of the
to the Stars Academy Dot Com page,
you'll see shots of it.
We're a little thing's glowing and is
getting beamed up into the sky.
That's the air force.
Yeah.
My guys were on that project.
Little thing's glowing or.
Yeah,
like a mass though.
Like a satellite?
Yeah.
They're called cube to cube.
Sat is a cube.
Sat is a modular box that you put
together as modules based on what you
need.
Okay.
I need to thrust her.
I need a sensor and I need a fucking rf
signal thing to send the data back home.
So now you've got three little boxes
attached.
That's a cube set.
They call them cubes,
so it's essentially,
um,
it,
it's probably 80 percent of the
satellite business,
but now they got to put all these cube
sats together on Musk's rocket that's
also launching giant satellites for dod
or whatever,
but it's super expensive because you
have a rocket and you have all that
fossil fuels and all this stuff.
If he launched these cube sats with
lasers because they're not that heavy
and you can,
like I said,
it would take a cost of launching a
cube,
sat from 50 grand a pound down to five
grand.
That's huge.
So there's the video of this actually
happening.
That's on your,
what is the,
to the Stars Academy Dot Com is.
And you can watch the,
you can watch the video and then you go
to the entertainment division,
which is my primary spot.
Um,
you know,
making movies and selling millions of
books and licensing this stuff out is
the diff,
is the reason why Disney's $300 billion
in warner brothers is 5 billion warner
brothers just makes movies.
Disease makes they make franchises and
they're vertically integrated.
We put up the book,
we put out the t shirts,
we make the movie.
So that's really where we're going.
And we have,
um,
we have three television series that are
probably one of which will be announced
probably in the next couple of weeks.
The other two were a little further out
on that.
The first film,
uh,
our first film is first quarter of next
year.
I wrote that one and I'll be directing.
That one's called strange times,
which is like a hard,
our version of the goonies but funny but
scary and fucked up.
But with 17 and 18 year old kids,
um,
and then,
uh,
and then secret machines,
the motion picture,
that's,
these are all franchises.
So strange times has an animated series
that's coming out.
We have wonderful writer from.
Sorry,
I live,
that's show running the thing.
We have an unscripted show coming out on
the entire company just following us in
a very national geographic way as we do
all these things.
And as we build lasers,
as we're on the movie sets,
as we're in the lab,
you know,
pinging that,
those,
uh,
those pieces of metal I told you about.
So,
uh,
there's a lot of things like that going,
um,
so when you ask about how do we monetize
all this shit,
we have a full functioning entertainment
division has been up for a few years.
That's what I've been doing.
And that's how I made the book.
And we've put out seven novels already.
Your end goal is ultimately to expose
all of this information.
My American,
my end goal is not just that my end goal
is to build a company that changes the
world and by doing a traditional IPO in
the next five to seven years.
And to do that,
I grabbed very,
very high ranking people from various
areas in the government to achieve all
this stuff.
And they,
they don't need to come in on the
movies.
I have that on lock.
That's my thing.
But it can,
it can function as a way to help people
understand what the fuck is going on.
So some of the movies,
some of the TV series,
some of the nonfiction works that we do
will all be about that subject,
but the rest of it won't be all right
dude.
Well that's a very ambitious project and
let us know when you're ready to go to
the moon or Mars or wherever the fuck
you're going to go.
Yeah,
you can go to your anus all those
places.
And uh,
I hope it's all real.
I'm excited.
Cool.
Thanks drew.
Thanks for having me.
Oh,
thanks for coming on rather than.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Bye.
Everybody.